blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
let's jump right in because there's so
much to discuss today i believe it was
two weeks ago
we did a live stream covering this
horrible
mass shooting that took place in san
jose
and i was saying and many people in the
audience were saying as we were watching
the press conferences and the calls for
thoughts and prayers and
uh support of the families and all of
this stuff
are we ever going to do anything are we
even going to get a proposal to do
something that might actually
do something about what's going on and
the the biggest problem
arguably in the united states is gun
culture and it's the idea of seeing
firearms as something to
bolster masculinity something to make
political points
something to solve interpersonal
problems and of course
if we resolved that there would be way
fewer other problems to figure out now
that's not the case the situation is far
more complicated than that and so as a
result
we need to do other things i'm really
glad to say
even though who the hell knows if this
has any shot of becoming a reality
about two weeks after that incident in
which
the gunman shot nine co-workers at the
san jose light rail yard
cnn is reporting that the mayor of san
jose
is proposing something that i've talked
about before
other gun safety advocates have talked
about before but
has not really been taken very seriously
anywhere which is
a restriction that would require gun
owners
in the city of san jose to obtain
insurance for their firearm if they are
a firearm owner
you must get insurance sort of like you
do with a vehicle
the vehicle although it's
primarily for transportation uh you can
do really irresponsible and dangerous
dangerous things with a vehicle
things can also happen to the vehicle
and so in most states you're required to
have
insurance on the vehicle much the same
way
you could require gun owners to have
insurance because they are gun owners
as well as the proposal is to pay an
annual fee
to cover the cost of gun violence and um
this is uh one of those things that
it most of the discussion is about let's
ban this type of gun let's ban that type
of gun
that's something that we should be
looking into uh universal background
checks
absolutely but treating firearms the way
we treat vehicles
which includes licensing requirements
and
re-licensing requirements as well as
mandatory insurance in both
in most states is actually a really good
idea
now the the mayor of san jose is sam
licardo or lechardo i'm not sure how
it's pronounced
he unveiled this earlier this week and
he said quote if we cannot stop the
horrors of gun violence in our cities
and this is important because just
requiring insurance won't actually stop
gun violence
but he says if we cannot stop the
horrors of gun violence in our cities
at least we're going to have the public
stop paying for it the second amendment
protects the right of americans to own
guns
but does not require that every other
taxpayer pay for that right
requiring use gun users to pay fees will
help fund
critical emergency medical and police
response and reduce
our taxpayers burden the way the
proposal would work according to cnn
is all gun and ammunition purchases
would have to be recorded on video and
audio to discourage
straw purchases where people who are
legally ineligible to buy guns
figure out a way to get a gun through a
straw purchaser
the straw purchasers would be far less
willing to do that if they knew that
every
transaction that was legal at some point
it's a legal gun
um that they would be less likely to do
that additionally
suicide prevention materials would be
required at point of sale
this is taking seriously something that
many gun rights advocates point out
which is hey a lot of these deaths are
suicide okay yeah
so we we basically have three categories
of problems with gun violence
we have suicides there's no reason not
to admit that that's an issue
that is dealt with very differently than
individual handgun homicides you will
often hear the rights say
you know all this focus on ar-15s most
of the deaths are coming from handguns
well we need an approach for handguns
and then you have the mass shootings
these are
three different problems all under the
umbrella
of gun violence and gun death and we
need different approaches
for each of them lechardo's or licardo's
proposal also includes leveraging
federal information for early
intervention
this is something that's relevant
because we often will hear and in the
case of san jose
it was the case that the gunman had had
a previous interaction with law
enforcement he had been detained
by customs and border protection
officers who discovered books on
terrorism and writings
that were filled with hatred towards his
workplace he ended up shooting up
his workplace a san jose police were
never notified
and uh had no idea that this is someone
that should have been on their radar
um and there there's a lot of good meat
to this proposal now
the gun rights people of course are
going to be against it
however not all of them are against it
and i've said this before
you know it's not just republicans who
own the guns
yes it's it's it's probably more than 50
but i know many people on the left who
also own guns
and every single one of them
particularly in blue states
is fine with all of this stuff because
they realize
that it makes sense for there to be some
hurdles to clear
to obtain firearms if you think driving
comes with significant responsibility
and licensing makes sense and insurance
makes sense and
re-licensing and registration fees and
all of these different filters make
sense
um as as my liberal friends tend to
believe uh then it follows that the same
would be
a requirement of something like firearms
you're not restricting the second
amendment by putting these restrictions
in place
you are not limiting one's ability to
obtain a
firearm uh if as long as they are
willing to go through these processes so
i have no idea if this will go anywhere
in san jose
i have no idea if there would be
problems um from from higher courts
on uh legal challenges this is just step
one
but i've been talking about mandatory
gun insurance for years at this point on
this program
and i'm really happy to see that this is
actually being proposed
let me know what else you think oh and
let me mention speaking of what else
um changing culture around using
firearms in the united states
there are examples of countries with
lots of firearms that don't have our
problems and the difference is the
people
the p we have a problem with the people
in this country seeing firearms as a way
to solve problems and listen universal
healthcare
there's no doubt that if you really want
to take seriously you know if you're a
gun rights activist and you want to take
even if you're cynical in your desire to
take attention off of
um mass shootings and and homicides by
putting the focus on suicides
if you want to be serious about that
then
support universal healthcare of some
kind whether it's medicare for all
whether it's some kind of provision for
mental health care that is always
available
regardless of insurance status because
if you really want to deal with suicides
and by the way mass shootings and
individual
handgun homicides how are we not giving
people
full access to mental health care so if
you want to really put your money where
your mouth is as someone who claims to
if you're on the right
and and say the real problem is suicides
what is your plan for getting healthcare
to everybody
so that everybody has access to to a
therapist
and to whatever it is that they need
along that front but my question to you
is
let me know what else you believe is the
lowest hanging fruit
as far as firearms are concerned
this next segment is one of the most
embarrassing
humiliating segments i have ever seen
because it combines the pathetic
political perspective
and cynicism of fox news with
sending a reporter who has no business
speaking spanish to the border
to try to speak spanish fox news has
been playing up this narrative
that there's a crisis on the border that
was caused by joe biden it didn't exist
up until january 20th um and that joe
biden and kamala harris are ignoring it
because they refuse to go to the border
this is the
the story that they've been telling so
fox news sends a reporter
uh to the border to talk to people and
they decided to send griff jenkins and
griff jenkins
listen this is a guy who's been
embarrassing himself on fox news for a
decade
but he goes and talks to a random guy
who's just in the river and he's
believed to be in later we find out that
he is someone who helps get people
to the u.s mexico border who are looking
to cross into the united states it's
just a random guy sitting in the water
and up walks fox news reporter griff
jenkins
and tries to speak spanish and this you
just have to see let's look at the first
clip
uh check it out smuggler is coming over
towards us
i'm just gonna take a moment and ask him
a few questions
hola come here
now i don't even know what he said there
remember i'm a native spanish speaker
what i think i heard is more
los manos rather than las manos
mor los manos de ambre which
translates painfully literally as
more the arms of hunger and again i'm
like doing the best i can to make sense
of the syntax here
um so then the guy has no idea what's
going on
and is just sort of waving and overwalks
griff jenkins and this continues
so there jenkins is asking in a very
strangely phrased way
how much are you getting paid for
helping immigrants
cross the border the guy says nothing i
think that
unfortunately as embarrassing as this is
the average fox news viewer sees this
and thinks wow
this is like really good investigative
journalism this is great stuff
and that's a media literacy problem as
much as this is a really hair brained
idea by fox
my guess is a lot of their core viewers
love this let's continue and this is my
favorite part
okay well neil he's not saying anything
about how much he's getting paid or if
he has a message for president
biden but he does say that more people
are coming
not entirely sure why the smuggler is
sitting in the middle of the river here
we're going to continue to monitor it
and bring it to you as we get it neil
incredible i just love that because
first of all
why would this guy have a message for
joe biden
uh but i love that he says la
presidente biden which is the feminine
form of the question implying biden is a
woman that we have a female president
it's not on purpose it's not like this
guy's trying to emasculate biden
he just has no idea how to speak spanish
and this was a bad idea from the get-go
so then apparently producers just love
this so much they
the producers were thrilled so they they
got more of this footage
uh fox news asking a guy sitting in a
river for his opinion on american
immigration policy
and joe biden
not coming for you so here the guy seems
to be saying
i only come to this point i don't go any
further
because that's beyond the border that
would be illegal i'm not doing that
and this guy is scared and i would be
too
and then jenkins again starts up with
the biden questions
see el presidente biden
habla frontera eserado
so what jenkins is trying to say there
in some of just the worst spanish that
i've ever heard
is that joe biden says the border is
closed
and this guy responds but no one's
understanding each other
and it's a complete and total mess
coming in
so the guy says well build the bridge
then people are tired
and the reporter says again but it's
closed the border is closed and the guy
says well open it
but it's not legal to go beyond the
river so that's why i stop here when i'm
helping people
but the best part of this is the guy
says
when asked for his message to joe biden
he says oh no we i have no problem but
you know do do what you're doing you
guys are good not exactly the ominous
threatening message
from coyotes that fox news wants us to
believe
uh and it continues getting more and
more interesting
in mexico a mexico
that is just the best the guy says you
know in mexico
the police are no good you guys are good
i respect you
uh i don't even think jenkins has any
idea the conversation that he's having
with this guy let's watch a little bit
more and
um por que
uh por juan por que
cruzar migrantes paraguay arles
also americano
yeah so so then jenkins asks why are you
helping people cross
and the guy says to help people that are
struggling
for the american dream he literally says
for the american dream
because here in mexico they're screwing
people
so a few thoughts on this first of all
this guy is incredibly
sympathetic if you can understand him
which you know it
you really can't unless you speak
spanish because what's going there's no
translator it's just a pathetic mess
if the idea is to frame what's happening
as really bad people helping really bad
people cross
it fails if you can understand what's
being said this guy is super sympathetic
to me
but more importantly no one really knows
because there's no translation this guy
speaks no english
griff jenkins speaks speaks essentially
no spanish if you want to do this
seriously
you could do it seriously this is a
sideshow they turn this into a freak
show
jenkins doesn't even speak spanish you
don't know
what the guy is saying uh and you you
you really can't actually do
justice to a segment that could be quite
interesting if you want to do this you
bring in a translator
and you might actually have a serious
segment here griff jenkins should be
ashamed of himself so should fox news
let me know what you think you can find
me on twitter at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to
blinkist.com david pakman i've put the
link
right underneath this video remember
that the david pakman show does depend
on the support of
people like you who get a membership at
joinpacman.com we produce an
extra show every day really every
weekday okay we take weekends off
for our paid members and you can get
instant access to that bonus show
by signing up at joinpackman.com i do
want to take a quick look at the david
pakman show
subreddit uh find it at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t now uh more than 31
000 of you subscribed to the subreddit
here is a post that i find interesting
and it's called
sometimes i fear being judged for not
wearing a mask
after being fully vaccinated and this
viewer says
right now in california june 15th the
mask mandate is going away and i'm
personally pretty excited for it i was
fully vaccinated in march got my first
dose in february
when i randomly got a text saying my
local vaccination clinic had spare doses
i immediately lined up i've been seeing
a lot of comments
on left youtube videos and subreddits
saying what the cdc did was stupid
or we should keep wearing masks forever
because they prevent the flu
and that kind of worries me not that i'm
judging anyone for continuing to wear a
mask but that people might decide to
yell at me or judge me for not wearing
one at a grocery store without a mandate
once the california mask mandate is gone
i've heard stories in san francisco of
people getting harassed outdoors for
not wearing a mask even though it's been
months since the cdc and california
government said it was okay
do you think people will end up judging
me or seeing me as a republican if i
stop wearing a mask indoors once the
california mandate is gone
yeah i mean the truth is some people
will and
there's going to be a readjustment
period and uh
i think that people essentially just
have to decide
what is more important to you is the
belief and understanding that the cdc
guidelines for vaccinated people
feel okay to you uh more important
than the fact that a couple of people
might
give you a dirty look because you're not
wearing a mask and it's just a very
personal decision as i've said before
i think it's great to have the
possibility of wearing a mask and for it
to be normalized
during flu season and particularly if
not only
if if in november it starts looking like
we're having a heavy flu season
against which i will be vaccinated i get
my flu vaccine and covet cases start
going up
i will be glad to when i go i mean
the real place i'm thinking of is the
grocery store or public transit
i'll be glad to go back to wearing a
mask i think that that's a great thing
um that being said right now with cases
so low
with the variant so well controlled by
the vaccine by the uh
by all vaccines i'm comfortable not
wearing a mask
outdoors and when it comes to indoors
just doing what the location requires
and if they don't require
require wearing a mask i'm comfortable
not doing it and
um is anybody judging me probably
probably but i'm completely comfortable
with it it's a very personal thing
and uh i think a lot of it is just
personality driven what what is more
important to you
saying there's no reason for me to wear
a mask based on the medical guidelines
so i'm not going to regardless of the
consequences or i value more
the way that people see me even if it's
random people
um that's a very personal decision that
really only you can make for yourself
another interesting post on the
subreddit asks
how do you guys stay sane i just
finished pacman's show from yesterday
and i've got to say
it's depressing from gridlock in the
senate to trump still having a large
base of support i find myself so
discouraged and turned off by politics
right now
how do you guys keep from being this way
going on to say later i live and work in
a very conservative area so i'm
inundated with this stuff all the time i
hear really racist homophobic things at
work all the time
how do my fellow liberals in
conservative areas cope the latter part
i can't answer
but i think it is really healthy to
check out from the news
for a few days every single week for
when i'm done producing the friday show
i do not pay attention to the news
unless something
major happens or unless i stumble across
something because i turn the tv on or
uh look at facebook i am checking out of
of news
for almost three days every week okay
that's like almost half the week in a
sense i think it's imperative
i think it's absolutely imperative to
maintain sanity and i would encourage
uh i would encourage people to do it and
then the other thing is
adopt a bit of stoic philosophy
about really understanding what is
within your locus of control and what is
not
because there are always things to be
upset about because so many upsetting
things are happening
but to some degree understanding the
limits can we
activate about something and try to
influence a political issue great let's
do it
but understand that you can't control
the outcomes of everything that's
happening
and to some degree we've got to continue
living our lives and make making the
best we can of them so i i think that
that would be my advice
but i'm right there with you two really
good posts today
make your own post and maybe it'll make
it onto the show next week
on the subreddit find it at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t one of donald trump's
favorite
economists made the argument on fox news
this week that there are people
like minorities who simply aren't worth
the 15 per hour minimum wage that many
on the left
are advocating for right now i'm talking
about
art laffer art laffer is the guy after
whom the
laffer curve is named this is the
relationship between the rate of
taxation and
total government tax revenue the idea is
if government tax the tax rate is zero
then the government takes in no tax
revenue if the tax rate is 100
the government also takes in no tax
revenue because why would anyone do any
work
if all of your money goes to taxes so
then once you understand that
you can find some point on the curve
that
maximizes government tax revenue
laffer's view as a supply cider
is that to maximize tax revenue you go
with a lower
tax because people are more productive
and therefore government revenue
goes up he's right the concept is a fair
concept
the way that laffer applies it uh
applies his own economic views to it
doesn't really uh
make any sense now trump loves this guy
lots of right wingers love this love
this guy
so he goes on fox news on tuesday to
argue there are
poor people and marginalized people and
people of color that just aren't worth
15
an hour and look at how casually he says
this
okay austin wants to talk about the
current mcdonald's ceo
kemczinski he's noting that artificial
intelligence technology has 85
accuracy with filling orders with
workers having to step in for
approximately one in five orders
it's going to be a big leap he says to
go from 10 restaurants to 14
000 restaurants but there is no doubt
they are working in that direction art
yeah for those people sandra who are
coming into the labor force brand fresh
uh not old-timers who've been around for
a while the poor the minorities are
disenfranchised
uh those with less education young
people who haven't had the job
experience
these people aren't worth fifteen
dollars an hour in most cases
and so therefore when you have a fifteen
dollar an hour minimum wage
uh they don't get that first job they
don't get the requisite skills to earn
above the minimum wage and after a
few years they become unemployable and
after becoming the unemployable they
become hostile
and that what you'll find happening is
this technology is created in an
underclass
of people who are really just bid out of
the labor market and will remain out of
the labor market
for most of their lives and this i think
is just a tragedy
so understand he's not listing a
combination of traits he's not saying
you know
people who are poor and disenfranchised
and less educated
who are disproportionately minorities in
the country because of these historical
reasons
that would be bad enough to say they're
not worth fifteen dollars an hour he's
just saying
people from groups like these people
like the young aren't worth fifteen
dollars an hour
people like the uneducated aren't worth
fifteen dollars an hour people like
minorities aren't worth
15 an hour it's a total mask off moment
for this guy if you want to argue
that in some low cost of living states
there are
some jobs where 15 an hour doesn't make
sense based on
the simplicity and the transience of the
job
we can talk about it i'll probably
disagree with you but maybe not but
that's a real conversation that we can
have but to say
lots of minorities just aren't worth 15
bucks an hour
that's another level guys that's on
another level altogether and and while
we're at it
why is being poor a sign that you're not
worth 15 per hour
if you have the skill that the job
requires
uh and the wage is 15 per hour in the
market
then why would your pre-existing
economic status whether you're poor or
rich why why would that make a
difference
it's nuts and if we decide that human
labor
is to be compensated in a dignified way
at fifteen dollars per hour
why does coming into the job poor make
you less worthy of that wage
it's all and completely insane and the
other aspect of this
is that if we accept summer all of
laffer's argument he's making a really
strong case for universal basic income i
don't think he knows it
the context of this segment was
automation automation and technology
is going to start by taking out 15
an hour jobs but then it's going to
start taking out 20
an hour jobs and then other jobs as
technology develops
if that is really his argument then why
not a universal basic income
and then one other aspect to this in
lots of places
even 15 an hour jobs aren't being
filled right now now i think it's going
to be temporary
uh the enhanced unemployment that's
ending in september
is a factor we have a sort of unique
circumstance right now in the aftermath
or as we start exiting the pandemic
i think by september people are going to
need jobs and they're going to be filled
but this is also a signal that in some
cases 15 bucks an hour is too low
he either doesn't get it or doesn't want
to acknowledge that
all of their arguments economically
depend on these simplistic
one-size-fits-all principles
hey it's your money why would the
government tax you
that's theft that's a really simple
principle simplicity plays well with a
lot of people
but it doesn't encompass the complexity
of the real world and
so do so do these ideas here and then of
course
it's the dehumanizing language the
people aren't worth
15 per hour rather than these jobs don't
justify a 15
an hour wage the the i know it's a it's
a minor thing but it gives you a little
bit of
insight into how these people view other
people just a disgusting person
and fox news just welcomes him with open
arms the host didn't even bat an eyelash
when he dropped this in there we'll have
more
from this art laffer appearance on the
david pakman show
instagram which i hope you're following
at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
andy norman who studies how ideologies
can
short-circuit minds he's the author of
the recently released book
mental immunity infectious ideas mind
parasites
and the search for a better way to think
andy it's so great to have you on today
thank you david it's a pleasure to be
here you know there's all these
analogies
these days uh to infection
and immunity and and inoculation and
vaccination and you talk about the
concept of
a mental immune system and a cultural
immune system can you tell us a little
bit about those ideas
yeah so just as our bodies have immune
systems that protect us from infectious
microbes
our minds have immune systems that
protect us from infectious ideas
these immune systems aren't talked about
a great deal in the sciences yet but the
sciences are waking up
to the fact that that they exist there's
now a mountain of
evidence that they do exist and had to
exist
because the wrong ideas could get our
ancestors killed
and so we're learning to actually
science is actually learning to view
minds as having filtering systems
that are meant to fact to screen out bad
ideas and let in good ones
and of course they can malfunction in
all kinds of ways that lead to social
dislocation and uh political
uh turmoil among other things so
sometimes people will ask me
you know what what is the best way to
protect oneself from
fake news and disinformation propaganda
etc
and in my mind the inoculation that i
suggest
is a foundation of critical thinking
and understanding how we evaluate
whether something we've been told is
something we should believe
and understanding how media works and
and media literacy
is that an example of such an immune
system
absolutely so i think the concept that
comes closest
to mental immunity is critical thinking
uh and and so if you want to get a good
head start on an
understanding of mental immunity start
with critical thinking for sure
it turns out though that the concept of
critical thinking is a very crude
instrument
for helping to build mental immunity
and and it turns out the critical
thinking skills can be weaponized for an
ideology
not just employed to create fair-minded
uh thinkers can you give an example of
how of how
that can happen well sure so i think
universities have been cranking out
people who are
trained to one another degree in
critical thinking for
decades and decades and often what
happens is that i meant
that a college graduate will
use their ability to dissect arguments
to defeat arguments they dislike but
not employ them to clarify or modify
their own thinking
so is that sort of a confirmation type
bias use of a tool
exactly so psychologists call
confirmation bias the tendency to
basically let in information that fits
your
political or ideological preconceptions
let those in uncritically but then
respond
critically or cynically to information
that
that challenges your point of view and
the problem with that is it's a recipe
for closed-mindedness and tribal
tribal thinking and we absolutely need
to get past that
if we hope to actually become wiser
versions of ourselves
when it comes to specific rhetorical
tactics i'd be curious to see
what you found about what is more
effective ver
versus what is less effective we've
talked on the program about things like
using a socratic method of questioning
to get one
to re-examine their own beliefs and come
to the conclusion themselves that they
may be mistaken this is sort of
in a sense i think an idea from dale
carnegie from the 30s or whenever he
wrote
how to win friends and influence people
um the defeasibility question which is
what evidence if it existed would get
you
to change your mind and then using that
like as a jumping off point i mean
are these are these tools may be
effective
uh absolutely so in the book i argue
that the
famous socratic method basically a way
of testing ideas with questions and
seeing
if they can withstand questioning that
that's one of the most powerful mind
inoculants
ever invented and in the book i take
that mind inoculant and refine it into
something i call the new socratic method
which i argue can be something like a
mind vaccine
and take our critical thinking to a
whole new level
i also love the question what would
change your mind
that that is a powerful question for
both
uh strengthening and modulating mental
immune systems
um so just as the the body's immune
system can get out of
kilter and attack the body's own tissues
or let in covid
right let in the corona virus the mind's
immune system can get it
confused and attack the wrong things so
a conspiracy theorist is somebody who
becomes hyper cynical about
traditional um or mainstream sources of
information
and their own critical mindset
is almost like an autoimmune disorder i
was going to say it's it's almost like
this cytokine storm
we talk about with the pandemic where
the immune system goes crazy because
they're they're you know for whatever
reason i'm not a doctor but
uh like this overactive defense
mechanism
that's exactly exactly the right analogy
so cytokines are actually
antibodies uh the they're the things the
mind
the body's immune system produces to
fight off what it perceives to be a
threat
and sometimes the body's immune system
overreacts to something that's genuinely
harmless
so when you have an allergic reaction to
pollen
that's your body overreacting to
something that really doesn't harm it
it's the overreaction that makes you
miserable right and our minds can make
the exact
same kind of mistake we can attack
genuinely reliable information because
it comes from somebody on the other side
of the political divide say
and in this way our minds do more to
protect
our chosen identities than they do to
actually help us find the truth you
actually have to train your
mind's immune system to care about
truth and to care less about your
ideological identity
and when you do that you become wiser
yeah the conspiracy theory thing is
interesting
we've interviewed experts on
conspiracism and conspiratorial thinking
and they're you know how can you
distinguish between
healthy skepticism and what's on the
other side which is this
never-ending and unsatisfiable
cynicism which is often what is at the
core of conspiratorial thinking
yeah you're exactly right um i think
it's long been a tenet of the critical
think
of of critical thinking advocates that
we think critically we ask the right
questions but those other guys
right um they they're insufficiently
critical
but it turns out you can be too critical
for your own good just as it's possible
to be under critical it's possible to be
over
critical and so the a truly healthy
mind is one that strikes the right
balance between suspicion and trust
yeah that uh you know the
a lot of this as you sort of alluded to
is
i but my family is a huge mental health
family a lot of people involve you know
psychiatry psychologists etc
and there's this really common
psychotherapy question which is
what would it mean to you if what you
believe isn't true which is really about
one's identity kind of being tied up in
their beliefs and so
that's probably to some degree at the
core of why we attach
so much to the beliefs we come in with
and are
and those beliefs are resistant to
change that
that's right and it turns out that we're
more attuned to the usefulness
of ideas than we are to their truth so
an idea feels useful to us a lot of
times we'll cling to it
even after it's been debunked right
and and but to genuinely uh deepen your
understanding of the world and to become
to grow morally you actually have to
learn to care
as much or more about truth as you do
about
the usefulness of the ideas that fill
your health your head
i should say by the way that genuinely
wise people don't look only
at what i call upstream evidence for
truth they also
care about the downstream causal
consequences of what we believe
right both matter
the you know i'm thinking of the idea
that some
hold people who are economically
disadvantaged
that it's you know immigrants from
mexico
that are responsible for them either not
having a job
or having lost a job or whatever the
case may be
and that seems to fit that idea that you
mention of
there's a convenience to believing that
that there's a usefulness to that
because
maybe it takes attention away from other
economic factors that are truly
responsible or from whatever personal
responsibility there may be behind
one's economic circumstances whatever
whatever the truth is
that that's exactly right so scapegoat
scapegoating immigrants
is uh has long been a staple of
demagogues and what it does is it is
that it very reliably hijacks
mental immune systems of the demagogue
supporters
so if you peddle fear of immigrants
a lot of times the fear will uh trigger
autoimmune cognitive autoimmune
overreactions
right thereby duping your own followers
and by hearing by your followers i mean
a demagogue's followers one's followers
yeah
one's followers right um so so fear
mongers
actually are hijacking the minds of
their own
followers and many of us in america
right now
are easily triggered by the
propagandists
on our side of the aisle i know that i
catch myself all the time
um overreacting to the fear-mongering
of the some of the progressive activists
that i
tend to trust and respect
what about situations where maybe two
people with different views enter
uh to a conversation in good faith
really wanting to sort of like hash out
what what is the truth
and you get to this situation where it's
sort of like my source versus your
source and
we get through these initial steps where
we ask the questions on
what are you basing your view on and i
tell you what i'm basing my view on and
you tell me and and the sources just
sort of conflict and of course
a really deep study might show us the
ways in which statistics may have been
manipulated or whatever but it sort of
starts to get
we we end up in the weeds so to speak
what is it
what should be done in that case how can
we move forward towards truth in
situations like that
yeah um so
to actually work through such
disagreements in conversation requires
patience and the kind of patients that
we seem to have
forgotten the virtue of in this in these
break neck times
um but it but in principle right every
one of us now can fact
check things by pulling a device out of
our pockets and starting to google
things
but the thing to understand is that
there's a ton of unreliable information
out there and a lot of it
is on very slick websites or in
carefully
manipulated statistical analyses so as
to get you
to support one or another political or
religious ideology
right um so so you need to be
very skeptical you need to look closely
at the sources you
tend to rely on both online and in the
mainstream media and
and do your fact checking find out which
ones are really reliable and
ask yourself who benefits from peddling
this kind of information
and and what inter what incentives might
they have
for skewing it in a way that that might
manipulate
me last thing i wanted to ask you about
um there there's sometimes there's talk
of sort of like
benign conspiratorial beliefs and often
the one that's cited
is like flat earth as an example someone
who believes flat earth it's
okay you know it's kind of wacky but it
really
is not damaging but then the counter
that i've heard frequently is
someone who believes that likely doesn't
believe
only that and flat earth and
anti-semitism
have huge overlap etc how should we
evaluate
like which battles are worth fighting
and and sort of adjudicating some of the
because there's just so much that could
be focused on
and and kind of thinking through that
fantastic question david um
so our canadian research team just
came out last year with a study that
shows that
if you indulge in irresponsible thinking
in one domain
you weaken your mind's immune system in
ways that
compromise your ability to distinguish
fact from fiction in other domains
right so if you indulge in wishful
thinking
for the sake of of uh
of uh harmony with your co-religionists
you end up becoming more susceptible to
conspiracy thinking
more susceptible to science denial more
susceptible to propaganda
so you you can't say oh i'll just go off
and
indulge in uh wishful thinking in this
domain and expect it not to compromise
uh your your mental function um
so i actually argue in the book that
there's our minds have a lynchp
our mental immune systems have a
linchpin and that linchpin is
always yield to the better reason never
let wishful thinking
dissuade you from doing the right thing
which is to believe
as much as possible on the basis of the
best reasons and evidence available
so you when you begin to move away from
evidence-based thinking you start to
compromise your mind's funk
your mind's immune functioning uh and
don't think you can only go a little
ways down this path
and and not slide
further down that path because the
evidence shows that the slope can become
very slippery
yeah it seems like some sometimes going
to a slippery slope
is itself fallacious but in this case it
seems to really be a core
a core aspect of how that works uh the
book is called
mental immunity infectious ideas mind
parasites in the search for a better way
to think
we've been speaking with the book's
author andy norman really great having
you on i so appreciate your time
thank you david it's been a pleasure
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show i really can't believe
this is where the country is right now
but 30 percent of republicans three in
ten republicans
now believe that donald trump is going
to be reinstated as president sometime
in 2021
what the hell is wrong with this country
how are so many people this disconnected
from reality
is anybody else realizing how much of a
red alert disaster it is
that this many americans are so
ignorant to think that this is even
remotely possible
now before we get to the poll numbers
let me give you a little bit of context
over the last couple of weeks the new
york times
the washington post the national review
have reported
that donald trump believes and is
telling people that he will be
reinstated as president
around august now when initially some
people reacted and said no no that's
fake news
the right wing national review came out
and said not only does trump believe
that
there are multiple republican senators
who believe that david perdue believes
he'll be reinstated
martha mcsally believes she's going to
be reinstated
this is impossible there is no
reinstatement mechanism
we have a president we have a line of
succession the president would be
replaced by the vice president if
anything happens
then comes the speaker of the house for
now trump is neither i know earlier this
week we talked
about the possibility trump would run
for congress and then
try to become speaker of the house but
for now trump is not a former president
is not part of the line of succession
so one side of this is that donald trump
is starting to sort of lay the
groundwork
for a violent coup attempt that's one
side of it
but the other side is the people who
believe hey
they might just confirm the voter fraud
and then
trump's back in power they might
reinstate donald trump
and it turns out that 30
of republicans believe donald trump will
be reinstated in this
calendar year this is from a new
politico morning consult poll from
yesterday
which found that most americans realize
of course trump won't be reinstated but
29 percent of republicans
do think trump will end up somehow being
president again
this year almost just as shocking quite
frankly
is that 16 of democrats believe the same
thing
16 of democrats also believe
donald trump might be reinstated or will
be reinstated as president this year
please call in i don't care if you're a
democrat or a republican or an
independent
if you believe donald trump is going to
be reinstated this year please call into
the show next week i want to hear from
you
please explain to me the mechanism by
which donald trump would again be
president before the end of the year
how would it happen this is essentially
as unlikely as jesus appears
uh by august they're essentially equally
likely
and a question that's never answered
when you ask them
is by what mechanism or legal authority
will donald trump be reinstated what
precedent
would allow something like this to
happen
and this is how we get back to the coup
idea because
there is no such mechanism there is no
such president precedent
short of a violent revolution of some
kind
which probably requires the backing of
the really the majority of the military
to remove joe biden there is no way that
this could happen and that's why we keep
thinking
are they thinking of some kind of
violent coup
the other aspect about the 30 percent
that believe
that donald trump is going to be
reinstated is that
30 are willing to admit it and that's
something else we have to think about
there could be another chunk of the
electorate
that believes donald trump is going to
be reinstated this year
but has the sense not to admit it when
they're called
by a pollster that's a possibility for
sure so a substitute headline
would be 30 of republicans willing to
admit
they believe donald trump will be
reinstated and then another substitute
headline would be
30 percent of republicans believe
anything that comes out of donald
trump's mouth period no matter how
absurd it is
if you go to them in september and of
course trump won't be president and you
say
what happened explain what happened they
will come up with some excuse
and if 30 believe this then donald trump
surely could get re-elected in 2024
because they still love him and they've
learned nothing from the disaster
that was the last four years of donald
trump this is really scary stuff and
it's sort of like
best case and worst case worst case
these people are just dumb and they
don't understand trump being reinstated
is impossible
uh worst case they understand the idea
of reinstatement as
code that they should do some kind of
violent coup attempt and we're going to
see real violence
coming to coming up in the end of summer
the best case isn't good
but the worst case is really
significantly worse
yesterday we talked about this hearing
that took place on
tuesday in ohio where anti-vaxxers
showed up to support a bill
to ban any kind of business or employer
or school from requiring or even
encouraging
vaccination it's a crazy bill and we
talked about it yesterday
and yesterday we looked at some clips
from a woman named dr 10 penny
and it actually slipped by me that there
was another
really nutty moment where a woman tried
to prove that vaccines caused people to
become
magnetized and thus metallic objects
will stick to you
but the demonstration failed miserably
and so that you understand
the idea as i understand it is
vaccines contain metal pieces and so
when
the vaccine is injected into you
your body becomes magnetized and metal
stuff sticks to you
now even if the entire vac it's just a
few milliliters right even if the entire
vaccine was just
metal it's not enough to magnetize your
entire body
and what i mean by that is if you
suspend all disbelief about this and
just
accept everything that's being injected
into you is just metal
um it's not enough metal to make you
magnetized okay so but forget that for a
second
here's the the demonstration which fails
the woman first tries to put the key on
her chest
and it sort of sticks probably from
surface tension or sweat or grime or
friction or whatever
but then she tries it on her neck and it
just falls off it's clearly not
magnetized or she clearly is not
magnetized
and also by the way most modern keys
aren't even magnetic so we'll talk about
that in a second but take a look at this
yes vaccines do you harm people by the
way so i just
found out something when i was on lunch
and i wanted to show it to you we were
talking about
dr 10 pennies testimony about magnetic
vaccine crystals
so this is what i found out so i have a
key and a bobby pin here
explain to me why the key sticks to me
it sticks to my neck too
yeah so if somebody can explain this
that would be great
any questions so a few things here
first of all when the key sort of sticks
to her chest the chest is
slightly angled and because of the
material of the key and surface tension
and if she hasn't showered if she's
slightly sweaty
the key could stick there for a moment
it doesn't mean that there's anything
magnetized there
then it fails on her neck it just falls
right off but understand
the most absurd part of this is most
modern keys aren't magnetic
most keys are made of brass brass is a
zinc and copper
um compound and when you make brass it's
not magnetic
it's just it just wouldn't work it
doesn't make any sense like on
on on the face value of this on
principle
it just completely fails because the
keys aren't magnetic
to begin with it's so embarrassing on
multiple
levels that it is an incredible failure
here's a little super cut
of the same woman just check it out and
and
it's just unbelievable yes vaccines do
you harm people about magnetic
vaccine crystals explain to me why the
key sticks to me
somebody can explain this that would be
great
[Music]
any questions when i see this stuff
i do wonder whether like as a society
we're just regressing overall because
this
feels like we're going back into you
know the era
of faith healing and witch doctors and
this type of stuff
and um it's like it all comes down to
the key probably stuck to her chest for
a moment
because she didn't shower in the morning
it like that that's all that this
is and the answer for why it doesn't
stick anywhere else is
this is all completely absurd but
there's people who believe this stuff
and it's having real consequences i told
you yesterday or the day before
that in less vaccinated counties
including in places like tennessee
hospitalizations are up because if you
don't vaccinate enough people and it
seems like it's got to be at least 50
but ideally more um unvaccinated people
are going to get sick
and they're going to be hospitalized and
some of them are going to die
this type of anti-vaccine nonsense only
makes that more likely
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
excellent voicemail today about the
minimum wage and its effect on prices
take a listen to this
hey david it's dr ryan i was calling to
see if you
saw this new article about chipotle
they're raising their average wage to 15
an hour right and in order to do so
they've raised their prices four percent
and i thought it was really interesting
because i'm i'm curious
is that four percent the apocalypse that
conservatives have been talking about
if wages were raised to living wages
like fifteen dollars an hour
because i can't fathom choosing a four
percent
discount if it meant the person
uh that was serving me was going to be
paid significantly less
absolutely so remember when obamacare
passed
papa john's went nuts saying if we have
to give our employees health care we're
going to have to add 10 cents to the
cost of every pizza to which i said i
i don't go to papa john's but that
sounds great to me if you came to me and
said
david would you pay 10 cents more for
your pizza for the knowledge that every
employee has health care of course i
would
and you know a chicken burrito at
chipotle is six dollars and fifty cents
a four percent increase would be 26
cents so now you're saying
if i pay 676 for my burrito instead of
650
everybody makes 15 bucks an hour and
everybody now has more money to go out
and spend
at other businesses that sounds
fantastic there's another example from
mcdonald's from a few years ago that the
price of a big mac would have to go up
by about 10 cents
if everybody got whatever minimum wage
raise was being proposed at the time
that sounds great and the reason why
it's so small
is that labor is only part of the total
cost of a lot of these places they have
real estate costs they have insurance
they have management they have all this
other stuff
the food costs themselves you can give
everybody
a much better wage and you pay 26 extra
cents for a burrito which even for
people who don't make that much money
is not a dramatic change to be able to
say wow everybody now makes 15 bucks an
hour so
i'm not surprised to hear the numbers i
did see the story
and it should come as no shock to us
that it is not the apocalypse that the
right claims it to be
we have a great bonus show for you today
we'll talk about joe biden's new plan to
donate 500 million
pfizer vaccines to other countries we
will talk about
a new bit of news involving the capital
rioter ashley babbitt's family
ashley babbitt died at the capitol riots
um
her family is now suing for the records
on the officer who shot her
and val deming's congresswoman val
demings is running against republican
senator
marco rubio in florida i love it more on
that
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member
right now there's no need reason to wait
you don't have to wait till next week or
next month
sign up at joinpakman.com get access to
today's bonus show
and i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com slash david
pakman